كانت الأيام الأخيرة لسقوط حكومة قندهار الأفغانية في
كابول على حافة الهاوية ،
ثم فجأة جاء طالبان في
القصر الرئاسي ،
الآن قدم مسؤول كبير سابق في إدارة
غني ، سي إن إن لأول
مرة روايته التفصيلية لما
حدث قبل الرئيس.
هرب إلى
أوزبكستان لمدة ليلة واحدة ثم إلى
دبي حيث لم يكن هناك أموال
معه الآن ، قال المسؤول إنه
حرفيًا كان يرتدي الملابس التي كان يرتديها ولكن
لماذا حدث الانهيار بهذه السرعة
أولاً قال المسؤول إنهم فعلوا ذلك
قللوا من شأن الصفقات السياسية المحلية والقبلية التي
أبرمها الطالبان لتخفيف
تقدمهم وأملوا بموجب
النصائح الأمريكية التراجع عن التوحيد في
المدن ، لكن مدن مثل
قندهار الحيوية سقطت قبل أن يتمكنوا من القول ،
ثم قللوا من
تأثير الانسحاب الأمريكي على الروح المعنوية.
بدأت كابول تبدو غير مستقرة ، حيث
ساعدت الولايات المتحدة في التركيز على تسوية تفاوضية من
شأنها أن تؤدي إلى تنحي غني
جانبًا في
وافق الرئيس على المغادرة لضمان
السلام ، وقال المسؤول إن القلق كان
حربًا داخل مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها 6 ملايين شخص ،
علمنا أنه إذا غادر غني ،
فستكون المحادثات صامتة يوم الاثنين في
قطر ، لكن يوم الأحد ، ضربت طالبان
ضواحي كابول في ذلك الوقت.
حصل مستشار الأمن القومي لغاني على الطلب الأخير
بالاستسلام من رجل أردنا الولايات المتحدة بصفته
إرهابياً خليل حقاني من شبكة
تابعة للقاعدة حقاني ، أراد مفاوض لطالبان
طويل الأمد
انتقالاً سلمياً للسلطة
وأن تصدر الحكومة بياناً.  من
الاستسلام
لكن غني هرب ويصر المسؤول على
عدم وجود كبش فداء واحد هنا
لأن العملية لم
يسيطر عليها الأفغان بالكامل في المقام الأول
نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن الدوحة